something strange happened on Capitol
Hill today and this is strange outside
of the ordinary day-to-day strange
that's happening in our country right
now
it was strange and rewarding in the
testimony that Jack Dorsey from Twitter
was giving before Congress all right
wacko and that's all I can really
describe her as Lauren Loomer was
seeking attention and she got she got
attention all right but not the type of
attention that she thought she was going
to get let's take a look at the video
then you'll need 30 yep $30 down here to
have either a divider 7f 40 yet $40 to
have five five forty five seven have 50
not $50 down here to officer will you
escort this young lady out please
yep two and a half an hour five c57 hand
70 up two and a half now five so divider
seven I have $80 to five eighty five
ninety eight hundred out on a day and
and and the quarter one the quarter one
hand said about to do to it a quarter
yet two hands and amaya three able to
bond three hundred at three and a
quarter cut three and a quarter now hand
Panther and a so divide four hundred
year before for to court afford hand
we're selling the cellphone therefore
two quarter for half yet Ford a hand for
seventy five hundred five and a quarter
five at half I yield back
now I'm gonna be honest with you I don't
know I don't know how any of those
staffers sat there with a straight face
as he did this this was representative
Billy long Republican from Missouri side
note if I guarantee you if Billy long
knew she was Luber conservative he would
not have done that but thankfully he
didn't know and this amazing moment
occurred in which I do not understand
how those staffers sat there and did not
laugh and roll on the ground laughing
because I honestly thought that this was
one of those
messed up overdubs you know you know the
clips that they have on Facebook where
they do the voiceover and make people
say the strangest things and the most
funny thing this this is how hilarious
it was I honestly thought that this was
a gag that somebody did know this
happened in real life and it could not
have happened ladies and gentlemen to a
better person a more deserving
individual than Laura Loomer who is the
alt-right troll he's I mean
extraordinaire that's basically I can
say she is an outright hack
extraordinaire but she got upset about
this and this is what she had to say on
Twitter she said quote I'm not far-right
I'm a female Jewish real Donald Trump
supporter who is sick of being censored
and shut down by liberals in big tech
companies like Facebook and Twitter it's
highly inappropriate for a congressman
to auction all free speech and treat me
like a prostitute sorry Laura
first of all that's not gonna resonate
with anyone because your comparison your
analogy there is it's not quite right
you know I've never seen someone auction
off I mean I guess there was that that
movie taken where they were auctioning
off the the whatever you know but in you
know it doesn't really resonate with
anybody so I'm gonna even stop trying to
make sense of her nonsense the fact of
the matter is is that you try to make a
scene and got embarrassed yourself in
the most spectacular fashion in front of
the entire nation and this is happening
to a person who is the most deserving of
this type of embarrassment you alone
with will get to Alex Jones but this
entire faction of the far right who had
this victim complex for this there's
really no reason for me to argue in the
framework that they're giving us I don't
even want to argue the merits of what
they're accusing that these are liberals
and big tech companies silencing
conservatives first of all tell us our
got pulled out right on face book there
has been censoring censorship of leftist
organizations left-leaning media outlets
for years and nobody said in
thing but now Alex Jones gets pulled
down and the whole world loses their
damn minds so I'm not even gonna argue
in the context of that because
conservatives are doing just fine it's
really just Alex Jones who's always step
the boundaries of the of the terms of
service over and over and over again and
he finally got pulled down right but now
everybody's like all conservatives are
conservatives of being sisters
conservatives have hundreds of millions
of dollars tied up into media into new
media into their own radio stations and
to their you know this CR TV where they
have all these episodes and tens of
millions of viewers on Facebook every
single day they have hundreds of
thousands of now I'm sorry millions of
followers on Twitter every single day
how many how many YouTube channels from
conservatives miss me with this fake
conservative oh we are being censored
madness what you want is to be able to
force your agenda down the throats of
America unimpeded unhindered without any
ramifications for the things that you
say you want the ability to speak all of
the hate-filled rhetoric even to the
point of threatening somebody's life and
not be held accountable for it
no period and that's why I don't want to
argue within the framework they give us
because the framework is so ridiculous
conservatives have the run of the mill
in media everywhere you go everywhere
you turn conservative media is shutting
this stuff down I've got to remember I'm
on david's program so I can't cuss but
everywhere you turn we are inundated
with conservative media 24 hours a day
and yet they're there oh woe is me and
you even have some progressives you have
some progressives who are like oh we
have to stand up for the Alex Jones of
the world we have to stand up without
its Jones because if it happens to him
it's gonna happen to us eventually
it's been happening to us we've been
censored and nobody thought anything
about it and so now it's happening to
somebody calling the brain what is it
what is it about America why is it that
you all love to worry about something
when it happens finally to a
conservative white
man crazy man like Alex Jones but when
it's been happening on the Left all of
these years you had nothing to say and
again that's why I don't want to argue
it within the framework they're giving
us because it is so ridiculous the only
thing I'm really allergic to besides BS
is stupidity and this conservative
persecution complex is the epitome of
stupidity and I'm so glad that's exactly
why I'm so glad Loren Loomer who was
trying to peddle this conservative
persecution complex got embarrassed in
front of the entire nation it could not
have happened to a better person one of
today's sponsors is Skillshare which is
an incredible online learning community
offering over 10,000 high-quality online
courses on a huge variety of topics the
first 500 people who click the link
under this video will get two entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
you'll have free access to courses on
music art photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between
I think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you I just
took a really fascinating class on
watercolor painting which I am not yet
at the level of trying to perfect but
more the level of trying to learn even
just a little bit about our show is
giving you two entire months of totally
free access to every course offered by
Skillshare risk free if you click the
link under this video you'll have two
whole months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share your passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
ten bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry because it's only
available to the first 500 people who
sign up